[Music]
hello my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm joined
by two of my colleagues Andrew Jackson a
software engineer at Google and Josh
Hoch also a software engineer at Google
they are going to tell us about a pretty
exciting model being trained on top of
kubernetes and they're currently
training another go AI a game an AI
that's learning to play the game go
alright give us a little bit about this
project and how it got started
sure okay so deep mind is a different
alphabet company based in London and
they're mostly a research focused
company that wrote this paper that was
published in nature about mastering the
game of Go using tree search and deep
neural networks and this was sort of a
revelation because beating professional
go players has been a long-standing goal
in artificial intelligence it has been a
long time in coming where as deep blue
was about 30 years ago long time yeah
long time 20 20 30 years ago
go has seemed a really long way away
turn then out of nowhere deep minds like
oh by the way we did that and they
published this paper and it was kind of
a revelation and then later the next
year I think they played world champion
Lisa at all in Seoul they published
another paper where they said that they
didn't just train a network to beat a
professional go player they actually
trained it with no human input
whatsoever that it started from
essentially random noise and learned how
to play by itself so those crazy is that
this GUI I was better was better the
better fantastic that's fantastic okay
so that's that's the deep mind team now
this is a different group at Google that
you're representing here so this is not
a group at Google and we this is a side
project this is an enthusiast project
because that project where'd go players
who love the game go and we really
wanted to have a chance to play against
alphago but of course we couldn't so we
had to sort of rewrite it and so mini go
is an open source ground-up rewrite I
shouldn't even call it a rewrite it's a
implementation based on their published
work it shares no code we're not related
to that team at all
we have no relationship with that team
whatsoever other than the fact that
we're able to implement their published
papers and try and reproduce their
results interesting from a
reproducibility of results perspective
and also that this is an open source
demonstration you know they had built a
really fast performance solution that
was really baked into the Google stuff
as we assumed and so what we wanted to
do is we wanted to provide an excellent
example of how you could use the Google
cloud platform and really amplify and
leverage some very limited developer
resources to try and achieve some really
amazing results okay so this is an open
source project built on your 20% time at
Google our our sort of Friday afternoons
where we can work on fun things related
to the field now tie this to coop con
we're here at coop con and Copenhagen
and you guys just gave a talk absolutely
so we just gave a talk because the whole
way that we train the whole way we got
data was with kubernetes we had this
problem where we needed to create
hundreds thousands actually millions of
games in order to get the sort of strong
model right so what do we do we use
kubernetes we use machine learning okay
so punchline but I think the important
part here is that the the this is
reinforcement learning where the
algorithm has to create its own data to
train on and that creation of data is a
really expensive part of the really
expensive part of the overall process so
in other rich other reinforcement
learning applications like robotics
running these simulations that produce
the next iteration of data is really
computationally expensive whereas for
for the go domain for the domain of
playing go that can be very easily
parallelized in a very natural way so
the parallelization now know you guys
ran a huge model to train your
implementation and you use kubernetes to
orchestrate the playing of the games is
that is right that's that right more or
less that's right so we use kubernetes
we actually use gke and we created a
giant giant cluster and define giant
I think we were running what do you say
like 2,000 nodes right so we are yes GPU
instances right so not only we're using
a whole bunch of machines we're using a
whole bunch of GPUs to train our models
right and this this problem is
particularly well-suited for CUDA and
GPUs right absolutely so the reason why
is super you suited to GPUs is because
we're running things through machine
learning models through neural networks
it's just math just matrices and the
thing that GPUs are really good at is
actually running things through matrices
okay so each each game that was
simulated 20 some 20,000 games that were
simulated each of those ran in a
kubernetes pod as a container that's
right and we scheduled it at all these
pods all with the kubernetes batch API
the java VI and we said power loss some
way up and kubernetes just took care of
scheduling on all these machines that's
fantastic now can i docker pull this
image and I don't know run run a game
simulation for fun on my laptop
obviously not GPU accelerated absolutely
if you have a GPU accelerated version
you can do that as well
this will be a different image but for
sure we have these available you can
pull down the image we actually have a
UI attached to that image so you can
actually watch it play and see it think
as you as you do that that's demo that
we have I'd love to see that so how long
does playing a game
take a simulation you know if you don't
have a GPU it can take like quite a long
time it could be done you know we wanted
to think a long time take a long time
you wanted to think very quickly won't
take as long Joyce but with GPUs maybe a
couple minutes for a game a couple of
minutes a game almost all of the all of
the load is taken care of by the GPU
there's very little work that's actually
done by the processor if you using the
GPU
all right fantastic I would love to see
your demo talk us through this alright
so what we're seeing here is we're
seeing well what we'll see in a few
seconds I guess I should wait all right
what we're seeing here is we're seeing
we're gonna see min ago think it's going
to be trying to figure out what moves
will be played so on the left side we
see the principle variation and it just
decided that it wants to play this move
so now it's gonna be my turn
I'm gonna play there and then we're
gonna see mini go think again so I
decided to play there and mini go is
thinking white I'll play one then black
will play two then why delay three and
as those numbers move around it's
changing its mind about what it thinks
is the best outcome for both sides the
other graphs that we see here so this
board up here at the top is the actual
inferences that are happening on the
model right now so each of those is one
twentieth of the total number of
possible board positions that it's
looking at so just like how a human
would play the game while we try to
think ahead and anticipate what's going
to happen and then by visualizing what
will happen we then try and decide
whether or not we like where we're going
mini go is doing exactly the same thing
it's trying to read ahead and what the
best choices are for you the person and
essentially figure out whether it likes
where the game is developing so that's
what the top one is is that's each of
those inferences the middle one is all
of the different moves that it's
exploring the bottom one is the the
change in score for a given play on this
graph that you see in the upper right
hand corner is how it thinks the game is
going for each side as it goes up it
thinks one side is winning as it's going
down and thinks the other side is
winning and so all of that debug
information is all there so yet I should
say what are the key things is of course
min ego thinks much faster than we do
and that's that's why we're only
sampling 120 oh that's right so as go
players you know this is really
interesting for us to watch and see what
it's what it's thinking of what it sees
things that we maybe don't think of or
moves that we wouldn't think of and we
can also see what it thinks the
continuation is what will happen after
that so this is a really great study
tool and it's useful for us as go
players and I should say one thing
that's like super fascinating is like I
look at this game and I'm like this is
something that I would play you know
this this is actually looks like a very
human game to me right this is a smaller
model we should mention this is a 9 by 9
game of go the real
is actually four times as big as this
but this is a smaller version that is
easier for us to run locally and
essentially give a demo on a laptop
instead of on a big beefy GPU machine so
this is a smaller version it's a smaller
model as well but as a result that
doesn't really matter we've got
full-sized models as well you can
download those also off of our butt
bucket with all of our data so are you
ready to take on a human
yeah we've taken on humans this has been
playing in public against anybody wants
to play it on ghost servers it's still
it's still development and we're still
we're hoping that we can replicate the
results and then also start to explore
what else can be done with it what can
be added what other sorts of options
there are so there's definitely a lot to
improve there's you know always bugs to
figure out we're always making it better
if you want to find us on this is all on
github right under the tensorflow
repository so github comm / tensorflow /
mini go we'll take any sort of pull
requests comments issues complaints
conspiracy theories you know what of
what a fascinating fascinating project
just tie this back to kubernetes one
lasts you know one last bit so
kubernetes provided you some
infrastructure underneath without
without a kubernetes you know what would
have what would Europe what were your
options I guess so after I had finished
the initial implementation of this I
realized that the hard part wasn't
actually implementing the neural network
the hard part was figuring out how to do
this huge amount of self play and create
the data it's not just twenty thousand
games it's twenty thousand games per
model and you need to do 500 models
maybe you know so it's a huge amount of
this compute that I needed to figure out
how was I gonna do that when each game
takes minutes to play and luckily I knew
a guy who worked on kubernetes and I was
able to say hey Josh how should I do
this should I like script up a bunch of
bash you know to manage VMs correctly
like how am I gonna get this at scale
with only the open source tools because
I didn't have any of the Google
infrastructure to lean on I guess that's
the other piece right the infrastructure
you didn't have to provision a single VM
you didn't have to find a GPU I did have
to do a lot of work in getting the code
to work inside a docker image because
this involved making those docker images
very performant like Dockers abstraction
is well don't worry about what the
actual
is underneath but tensorflow and gpus
were very much trying to compile with
all of the processor optimizations we're
trying to compile with the latest Nvidia
drivers you know getting all of that to
work inside the docker image was
non-trivial but it's also gotten a lot
easier I think in particular with the
launch of GPUs on Jiki gke that whole
situation with getting the latest
drivers getting CUDA and kudiye and
installed
that's all come a long way and even when
we started this it was only like a six
months ago that it's come a long way
just since then so so it's pretty
exciting to see that sort of progress
but that hard part was was getting that
performance inside those containers so
it is interesting to see that that
containers are no barrier to this sort
of high performance computing if you
want to use GPUs and go as fast as you
can you want to use all of the extended
process instructions you can do that too
in your instances with just a little bit
of care and how you craft them so I
think this is pretty interesting it's
fantastic Josh Andrew thank you for your
time
you